les touristes sont revenus les hôtels de
la riviera maya font le plein comme si
la pandémie était chose du passé
soulagement pour le mexique qui n'a
jamais fermé ses frontières mais où le
tourisme avait fortement diminué
et ce malgré de nouvelles alertes à la
sécurité dus aux bandes criminelles de
plus en plus active
rien à craindre pour les grands hôtels
de cancun qui sont blindés de tous les
côtés les risques sont plutôt du côté
des stations comme playa del carmen ou
toulouse où on soupçonne que la drogue
circule et où bien des commerçants sont
victimes d'extorsions fin octobre une
poursuite entre bandes rivales s'est
terminée dans une pizzeria de tulum
tuant deux touristes et en blessant
plusieurs autres
en novembre des bandits sont venus de la
mer pour régler leurs comptes sur la
plage à deux revendeurs de drogue sans
faire de victime parmi les touristes les
hôteliers surtout les petits sont
inquiets c'est delluc de place donc il
considère qu'il ya quand même ici on va
dire et là c'est un gros marché sur la
sur la drogue il ya beaucoup de gens qui
viennent ici de plaine pays pour se
droguer et pour avoir un accès facile
aux drogues et donc forcément c'est un
grand marché et si c'est un grand marché
de la concurrence et les clans entre eux
se bagarrent pour tenir pour tenir les
les points de vente on va dire situation
intolérable pour le président mexicain
cftc chômage
national les six ans qu'elle s'est fait
douloureux ou des mexicains et des
étrangers perdent la vie ne doivent pas
se répéter
et pour ça pour la première fois il
envoie l'armée 1500 gardes nationaux et
la marine le mexique ne peut pas se
permettre de perdre la plus grande part
de son industrie touristique qui compte
pour près de 9% de son produit intérieur
brut il faut rassurer
des chaussons plus tranquille maintenant
les gens ne le disent avant c'était les
polices municipales et celles de l'état
qui était censé assurer la sécurité du
tourisme mais on doutait de leur
efficacité elles seront toujours
accompagné de la garde nationale dans
les déploiera le bon côté de ça c'est
que vu que femme vu que femme multiplie
les différents niveaux et des
différentes institutions du coup ça
permet d'avoir beaucoup moins de
corruption à présent la pizzeria de
tulum est fermée pour enquête sur
homicide et elle est surveillée en
permanence
même chose à l'hôtel de puerto morelos
où a eu lieu la dernière fusillade
surveillé par le nouveau bataillon
touristique plutôt bien accueilli
molotov elles sont tellement difficiles
oui c'est une question difficile mais la
base militaire me rassure 10e résidents
mexican beaucoup d'étrangers ignore tout
de ce qui s'est passé c'est le cas cet
américain de washington qui ne
s'inquiète pas c'est torontois sont au
courant mais n'ont pas peur
il ya bien une fusillade à toronto
récemment ce genre de choses arrive dit
elle
à playa del carmen on est en train de
démolir ce pionnier du tourisme local le
fameux blue parrot ou en janvier 2010
est une fusillade avait fait cinq morts
dont un canadien on les fasse tôt
l'envoi de l'armée à la riviera maya
hausse d'un cran l' escalade des mesures
prises par les différents gouvernements
mexicains depuis 20 ans pour lutter
contre le crime organisé ils veulent
absolument éviter que cette zone
touristique majeur connaisse le sort
d'acapulco où les touristes étrangers
n'osent plus s'aventurer depuis
longtemps à cause des guerres entre
bandes de narcotrafiquants
jean michel leprince est du canada qu'un
coup